don't demons
though this be our focused hour it may
yet be
your greatest moment
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after more than 20 years the dark
wanderer
has returned and once again he travels
east always east
diablo 2 is a landmark game for blizzard
diablo 2 resurrected is a full
hd remaster of both the original game
and the expansion lord of destruction
it takes the 2d sprite-based classic
that we love
and brings it into the present in 3d
utilizing up-to-date graphical rendering
and lighting technologies
it also includes modernizing all
27 minutes of cinematics
recreated shot for shot with the
explicit
intention of preserving both the look
and the pacing of the original movies
blizzard
has a long history of games that we're
proud of
and when we think about diablo 2 we
think about it
as a definitive pillar in our foundation
now it's funny to think that some of you
weren't even born when d2 was released
which
makes it all the more important that we
deliver an authentic experience
wherever you play we want everyone
to relive their memories or experience
the game for the very first time
on their platform of choice and so we're
excited
to bring diablo 2 resurrected to pc
and console along with cross progression
and for those of you who are in love
with the original
and you just wish it worked more
seamlessly
on modern computers you can bring back
all of that nostalgia exactly as you
remember
and enjoy the game in its original 2d
form
much like we did with starcraft
remastered obviously
there's a lot to talk about later today
diablo speedrunner mr lama will host a
round table
with members of the development team on
the dedicated diablo channel
if you are a diablo 2 fan i encourage
you to take a look